all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly thingss YouTube channel
welcome to morning coffee thoughts where
I give my thoughts over morning coffee
um today I wanted to talk about a
thought I had where I actually do agree
with the
Liberals now I know I know what you guys
are thinking Pearl they make zero
points and
normally normally I would agree um they
obviously make zero points um but I had
a
thought and this thought is that it was
something I heard someone say in a
podcast that body count doesn't matter
now I'd like to say to start I have
wholly because I don't want you guys to
clip this I don't want you guys to take
this out of context yes body count
matters less women are obviously
better than more women but
I was watching this girl that got
married at 18 on a podcast this chick
got married at
18 presumably she she said right she was
a virgin she's very religious all this
stuff and now she's been in a phase
for 3
years this guy on paper got a
chick that was everything he would want
she was
young
uh
she didn't have a lot of
experience and still still this chick
does the exact the exact same thing so I
thought to
myself even and
then the line that's going to be lined
up for women like that so like you know
a chick with no experience young
beautiful all that stuff it'll almost
make her crazy because how do you not
get an ego when you're everything that
that dudes want you know and what
percent of women are going to be tempted
by that and and still not do it I'm not
even saying they don't exist there a
girl I know a couple girls from like
church or my high school they would
never they would never
but
still it's common
enough it's common enough that we see it
we see it all the time it's not even
uncommon to have a girl married for 10
years and then just up and leave her
entire family so I thought to
myself it doesn't matter the way it used
to and I would be
curious what the stats will look like in
20 years because I bet you even the
women with very limited sexual
experience are going to be so
tempted by the the modern
world that many will take it and I was
thinking to myself if I was a guy how
would you
really how would you really
differentiate
between the chicks that are going to go
arai in like 10 years and the chicks
that aren't and I really thought to
myself I've seen chicks that on paper
were 10 times better than like like said
chick so like there was chick a on paper
would have been 10 times better than
chick
B but chick B will still go crazy so I
was like what is a guarantee for guys
and I'm
thinking if you can't even get a virgin
chick from the south to stay in her
marriage like
[Music]
what what what chance
do do you have with your cuz I mean what
percent of guys are going to get a
virgin chick from the south none
um what what chance do you have with
your your normal
chick anyways um so I thought to myself
I'm like when they say body count
doesn't matter it totally does obviously
the women with more sexual experience
are going to be more likely to leave the
women with less sexual experience are
going to be less likely to leave but in
2023 even that's not a guarantee
and the amount of
attention that the young pretty virgin
chicks
get I
mean good
luck it's all I have to say but this
isn't to be a Doomer I was just thinking
from like the men's point of
view tough tough tough pill to swallow
anyways
guys um I'm going to have announcements
about some stuff with the channel soon
but I can't tell you guys yet because
we're still making it but let me know
what you guys think in the comments
maybe I'm off base I was just thinking
of this but yeah like the video guys
I'll talk to you later